hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Super Mario maker now if
you're a fan of the game grumps like I
am then you've been watching their Mario
maker playthrough very closely but you
may have noticed that they stopped
playing the SuperDuper difficult ones
mostly because they want to live longer
in and not die of heart blood pressure
death physically in their life so I'm
gonna take your recommendation because I
know why you're here to see me be erect
with rage and then play these levels so
I'm gonna start out with Ross's levels
because it's highly asked for miss when
you play courts I don't know this is the
first time that I've loaded up Super
Mario maker so I've only played it a few
times before and oddly enough it was
when Ross was showing me his levels
before the grumps even started their
playthrough and I played this one and I
did damn good with it because I'm just
so how do i oh my god what is that how
do I turn that off go away I don't know
how to use you Wii U ha okay so now okay
there we go
alright got it cool okay so now that
threw off my mojo now I'm gonna do
terribly I know this for a fact but when
I play this for the first time I
actually made it all the way to the
second boss like the first time that I
played through the game which is pretty
amazing for me I mean admittedly I'm not
that bad at video games as you guys are
gonna see but they do tend to scream a
lot
I do the screaming thing boink Oh
titties I didn't know that was gonna not
work okay I got you I got you okay I
don't know if I should just go for the
girl for the kill because that would be
easier and safer or if I just should
just rush to the I'm gonna do this one
okay so I got this pretty well and done
because I am good good well I did pretty
good for my first go I mean it's my
first gift gab at it I mean it's doing
pretty good it's doing pretty good so I
have a lot of high hopes for how this is
gonna go I just need to be able to go
about it without losing my goddamn mind
and and I need to like I'm not an expert
at Mario I will be the first to admit
that but I'm skilled at talking and
playing at the same time and then
bullshit's gonna come pouring out of my
mouth and I'm not gonna be able to know
what I'm gonna dammit I think I could
see death moments before it arrives in
my face and that's not in the Family Guy
term of arrives where he was talking all
posh and then decided to blast his wife
with nevermind I'm not gonna continue
that thought I'm gonna continue this
game I sometimes forget exactly what I'm
doing when I'm trying to concentrate
very hard on [ __ ] that isn't very
important to me and I mean the main
point that people want to see me play
Martin Super Mario maker is mostly just
because no budget do you think you're
gonna get me oh the answer is probably
what I mean
Oh death was a minute okay I know what
are you huh yes okay there is a way and
I can do it but I probably should have
just popped on his head because that was
been the smart thing to do but I've
never claimed to be any sort of smart
god oh god damn it
that was gonna be so good I don't know
why that's thrown me I usually am pretty
damn good okay I know there's a secret
up here to the left but I want to try to
not use it because I'm a pro I'm an
amen' [ __ ] god damn it I'm a pro I'm a
pro at games I'm a pro at goodness doing
I'm a guy I'm the thing I'm a loser I'm
a loser baby so why don't you I forget
the rest of the song why don't you tell
me the lyrics the rest of sorry okay
here we go oh man I'm getting antsy way
too early
my first I it was because my mojo got
all thrown off I was doing totally fine
oh [ __ ] god damn it stop it with that
bull Thanks it's so hard to console you
know some people criticize you know
because they're like oh just just not
suck so don't suck so badly and that's
what people say in the comments below
but in reality you know there's a lot of
different elements to it at play there's
a lot of different things going on that
you could do there's a lot of different
reasons for being here and I'm gonna
show you exactly what a what I'm talking
about which probably isn't making a
whole lot of sense because frankly I
don't know what's coming out of my mouth
of this son of a [ __ ] why do that I did
the shrinkie do or I did the laydown you
do okay cuz this is what I'll get you
this is what will get you it'll you
you'll do sloppy and then you forget
exactly what you're doing and then
you're not supposed to be able to do
what you need to do and I know about the
twirly secret where it's not secret it's
a standard core gameplay mechanic but
I'm gonna call it secret because I'm
lame and I'm gonna call you an idiot
because I'm gonna bop on your head Oh
sassafras son-of-a-bitch that's so
sudden and so scary I mean I don't mean
it to be scary but it's gonna be fine
okay I know I can do this because I'm
good at games and stuff dirty games good
at games get it's okay cuz at least get
past this one part before we start
claiming victory about how good I am at
games Pam that's what I was looking for
hey whoa jeez Oh what you gonna do oh
crap come on that's a load of crap
oh I thought he was gonna what no it's
my spring stop stealing my thunder
breath okay here we go oh god stop
stealing the Thunder bruh
not my thunder brah my thunder Wow god
dammit I say I escaped I escaped death
just to join it once again in the end I
can do this I can do this guy's you just
gotta believe in me there's a lot of
there's a lot of
needing to be happened in my face that
sounded weird but you know what I mean
just believe in my face and then things
will go well for me oh man I was doing
so good what happened to me what
happened to me
I can't even go with the goddamn tube
rod cause I'm using the joystick control
and am-ness Frick you screw your face oh
god okay close god damn it I know I can
do this I'm all jittery now because
performance anxiety is getting to me you
know this never happens to me hey hey
just so you can you know last a little
longer than this most of the time this
is it too early for sex jokes cuz that's
all I got at this point my brain is
running on minimal capacity
oh I'm all jittery and twitchy it's not
good for me not good for anybody watch
them goddamn it if you would know son of
a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] ask to your face
oh yeah after shell you impaled my my my
ass with your sharp never mind
oh man see I never I never get this
nervous when I'm playing other age games
well I mean I do but then I just don't
care but now I have someone to live up
to because I know that wait I don't
remember dude the grumps ever complete
this particular level I don't I don't
know if they did they may they may have
they may have helped you okay come over
here be a dick okay that's that's what I
was hoping for this is what I was
looking for okay so now I just gotta get
past these sprayed ooze which is the
easy part
I mean the bosses aren't terribly hard I
mean if I was to take my time with them
then god damnit why does that keep
happening oh yes Pro oh my god so pro
okay don't [ __ ] it up thank you okay we
got this we rollin
alright alright
oh [ __ ] me god damn it I'm not I'm all
off my rhythm all off my rhythm but I
got this now that I know exactly what
I'm gonna be alright now I got this now
that I know exactly what I'm gonna be
doing I can do it with perfect vim and
vigorous Ness whatever the hell that
means
it's all ice only the first episode I
feel like I've been through a war I feel
like Rocky at the end of rocky you know
how rocky was at the end of rocky yeah I
was like that or I'm like that I'm like
that right now
whatever shut up I just watched Rocky
and Creed good movie great movie not
important top stop grabbing it stop Red
Dog
god damn it you suck ass no oh
what are you huh yeah suck that's what
you gonna do die I'm the greatest that
ever lived greatest that ever lived
I'm the greatest ever lived I'm
celebrating my championship hit the
goddamn spring thing oh hey ho just
thought I'd do a rain dance in the
middle of this don't mind me
Oh God ha ha ha look at me being good at
games and whatnot see cool huh
alright now this time don't run smack
dab into a hammer bro hammer that's a
hammer smack dab into the hammer bro
hammer but I sure did find something
else I think I landed crotch first onto
that fire ball thank you alright I can
do this alright I can do this don't
expect me to complete don't expect me to
complete a complete level per video
because that's definitely not gonna be
having at this point I know for a fact
unless it's gonna be an easy one because
maybe that's why the groom's turn to the
easier levels because their hearts oh
that was simple that was simple why
would I go over that why would I jump
over him when the option was to be
simple oh why do I choose to be so smart
and handsome and complicated well I
could just live
simple life I'm sweating already this is
not a good start for me I won serious
try one super serious try here
this is moneymaker this is gonna be the
one who's gonna be the one I can feel it
in my junk punk okay this is how I do
with you this is how I do okay this is
how I do this is how I do I was leading
you Bank this how I do with you okay
drop it oh god damn it
this is how I do with you this is how I
do boink okay thank you
please go away forever no one ever
really likes you in the first place if I
fall in the fire I will eat my own
eyeballs yes there we go okay
we're good I'm calm I'm collected I'm
cool I'm the coolest guy I know I don't
know a lot of people damn that but I'm
too proud to be defeated by the likes of
whatever the hell happened there because
I'm the king of something squirrels five
nights at freddys I don't know
this has nothing to do with any event
alright don't get hit by the fireball or
the hammer bro hammer Oh God it was so
scary oh man oh God god damn it ah son
of a [ __ ] alright I'm done for this
episode I'm gonna try I'm gonna keep it
a limit I'm only gonna do three maybe
only two episodes per level if I can't
beat it then I suck and that's probably
true overall so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'll try this again in
the next episode and as always I will
see you in this video